مشاهدينا خلف الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا دمارا هائلا ومشاهد ستبقى عالقه في
الاذهان وصدمات نفسيه سترافق الضحايا
اشهرا وربما سنوات خصوصا الاطفال الذين
فقدوا عائلاتهم في الكارثه وفقدوا هوياتهم
ايضا نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد قطاعي اشار
الى ان نحو خمسمائه واربعه وسبعين طفلا
ينتشر من تحت القاض مباني منهاره من دون
وجود اسرهم مضيفا ان نحو 76 طفلا من بين
هؤلاء التحقوا باسرهم فيما بعد في الوقت
ذاته اقابت مجموعه من نحو 200 متطوع بينهم
معالجون نفسيون واطباء اقاموا مراكز تنسيق
في الولايات التركيه المنكوبه وذلك بهدف
طبعا تحديد هويات الاطفال ومحاوله اعاده
بقيه الاطفال الى ذويهم واوضح اختصاصيون
نفسيون ان بعض الاطفال يعانون بالفعل من
عدم ادراك ما حدث لهم الى جانب معاناتهم
من قلق مستمر
[موسيقى]